- [Interviewer] You went
to the hospital for what?
- Heat stroke
- Heat stroke?
Today?
- Yeah.
I tried to make it back
faster, but I couldn't.
- That's okay.
I'm here.
You're here.
- I made it back alive.
Let's put it that way.
- Yes. So, Tammy, where
are you from originally?
- Here. L.A.
- You're from L.A.
And how long, how long have
you been living on the street?
- 41 years.
- And what, what were the circumstances
that got you down here?
- Bullies, homeless, mental
illness, in succession
when I gave up meth.
- Mental illness?
- Yeah.
- The bullies bullied me so much
that I ended up with depression.
- Do you have a family?
- Nope.
Not as far as I'm concerned.
- What do you mean, not as
far as you're concerned?
- In other words, they're
a bunch of assholes.
- Say that again, please.
- They're a bunch of assholes.
I had bullies in the family,
bullies at school.
You know, everything's
negative it brings you down.
- What do you do for money here?
- I panhandle my benefits.
- Do you get the government stuff?
- Yeah. Why do you think I pay for this?
- Yeah. Nice tent.
- Yeah, I've got to back it up when I can.
- I can.
- And where do you go to eat?
- I cook right here. I don't-
I can't eat most of the food they have.
- You cook here?
- Yeah, I've got a stove over there.
(laughs)
- Good for you.
- I take care of myself .
The best I can.
- Is this how you pass the time?
- Yeah.
- Nice.
- Can we grab a soda on the way?
- Sure.
I'll grab you dinner, too, if you want.
- I'll have the same thing you have,
how's that?
- You'll what?
- I'll eat the same thing you do.
- There you go.
I think that means we're dating, Tammy.
Do you have friends here on the street?
- Nah, I don't consider
nobody out here my friend.
That would be totally whacked.
- So, you have contact
with anybody outside?
- No one.
- So, it's just you all by yourself?
- Yeah.
- Do you get lonely?
Depressed? Anything like that?
- Not from that.
It's when they lie to me
and try to steal my shit.
That's what gets me.
Here.
- Beautiful. I'd love to start.
- Sorry. I missed you.
- It's okay.
- But I'm okay.
I got my head-
You know what I did?
After they jumped me I laid back down
and said fuck that and
stuck my head in the sink
and shook my head off
and bucked out the door.
I just had to be by myself, my way.
Cool off as I go.
- You're a survivor.
- Yeah, that what I learned
to do with heat stroke,
cool off quick-
but I took it slow coming back.
Took all the shady sides of the street,
which is what I forgot, you know?
- What's what's the worst thing
that's happened to you here?
- I'll just put it this way.
Some guy tried to attack me in my tent
when I told him no, go away.
Shit like that happens all the time.
- Yeah.
- Hey, these guys out here think
they're the boss of everything.
- You've been raped here?
- No, the one that tried got stabbed.
- What's that?
- The one that tried got stabbed.
- Oh, is that right?
- With a pen.
- Good for you.
Good for you.
- He's lucky I didn't get
me knitting needle out.
(laughs)
Or the crochet I had would've been worse,
the Afghan hook.
It's like I have crochet hook.
I have a knitting needle about that long.
- That'll hurt.
- Yeah, but there's
more going out than in.
- Oh, that's right. It's
got a hook at the end.
- There was a point in
time when I've thought
society was so dysfunctional,
it might've made me normal.
- Yeah. Yeah.
You're not too far off there.
- Sorry about that.
- About what?
- They say a high IQ comes
with a mental illness
that was along for the ride.
- Yeah, I buy some of that.
- I heard it on a radio talk show.
I was flipping through
trying to find some rock
and roll and I heard it.
- Tell me about your childhood.
- It was only the worst
nightmare and that was it.
- Why's that?
- Adoption.
- Oh, you were adopted?
- Yeah.
- At what age? Like right away?
- Three and a half.
- Three and a half?
What happened to your parents?
- I don't know.
I found out my brother died
on the way to the hospital
from something or another
that happened at the home,
and I decided not to find out anymore.
I dreaded it was abuse.
- Did you ever have contact
with your real parents after that?
- No.
- Never.
- Never even bothered.
I got about three paragraphs
in my bedroom and tossed it.
Yeah.
- Oh, you didn't even read it?
- The brother I would have had died
and my other sister had Down Syndrome.
- Really?
- Yep.
- You're lucky one.
- Nah, not really.
They're better off.
(laughs)
She gets taken care of
and he don't have to suffer about nothing.
- And you have children?
How many children?
- No kids
- No kids?
- Nope.
- I thought you said they're all assholes.
- That was your family.
- Yeah.
- Never married?
- Four times, they was real assholes.
- Oh, you were married how many times?
- Four.
- Four times?
- Yeah, jerk magnet is what I figured.
- What's that?
- Jerk magnet.
- You're a jerk magnet?
- Yeah.
- You're funny.
- There's the easier,
softer way of putting it.
- Okay.
- What's the harsher way of putting it?
- It was son of a bitches.
- Yeah, I like jerk magnet.
That's a good one.
- Hey, at least I found
a way to laugh at it.
- Do you have plans for down the road?
- Not really.
- Just muddle through until
it's my time to go see God.
Because that's all we really do anyway.
- Yeah.